okay so we're gonna put that stripe this
sound is the hand of the tokyo okay so
you're gonna you're going to yield
there's the strike right there
okay
okay so this i bring that target
in my pattern
it'll be about there
that's where my pattern comes in
hits
okay so
up the center line
turn
[Music]
but the weight pattern is the same
boom right there
okay so yield
boom in
once you're here you can see you can see
you you have the two
but i'm
the two contact points in the adhesion
but this is boom deep
and
right here
don't keep your elbow up
don't open yourself up
it's very tight quack
okay it's gonna be okay
i i'm kinda i definitely am pulling the
strike
um
but uke takes
a lot of the energy off because he's
doing new chemi so he has to reconcile
the young energy with the yin energy if
he stays following the adhesion
he will move his target
the neck
in correspondence with the strike okay
if you're getting killed on the neck
it's okay
let's go
keep going sean
push margaret
so you're on the outside
you're on the outside you want to be on
the inside
you're on the outside
[Music]
so i'm not getting out of the way and
hitting you there okay
this is very easy to block
okay so
you're pushing
i turn it
hi
okay all right
remember
striking's in a phone booth
right if i
if i could
[Music]
move this far
i would have in the first place okay
so
we're we started talking
but what i'm doing
because i'm close okay well my elbow is
anchored right here whoa okay
no not out here like that
striking is tight striking is a much
tighter than you think okay
hey okay now we're gonna go to katadori
okay
uh but i'm not gonna let him grab me
he'll do the same thing
inside
he it's a shoulder tap move
make sure your elbow is coming in that's
where your power is your elbow power
don't leave your elbow out
also free the uh ball and socket joint
so you have to turn your palm out just
like when you throw a ball that has to
turn out if you want to look very
uncoordinated don't turn it out same
thing here you look very uncoordinated
as it's moving out in
[Music]
okay
again
i'm pulling it
but he's the one that's responsible for
okay here we go
okay uh so somebody looked at me all
weird where uh
i said you can't enter and then tencon
okay
well you should have just done what i
was doing
okay
but
you're going to walk into that other
strike you see boom
so you don't do that you're coming up
[Music]
so he could throw the other stride
you still have the center line okay
you're not going to move yourself over
coming up
everything's happening inside
inside
okay so
uh we'll go to
[Music]
yoko man now okay and again don't throw
him from out there
scoot in
and he's gonna try to
boom
got it
boom well you followed the same way
the same way you do what show manucci so
when the shomonucci is going up
that's where i harmonize okay
so the strike is going up that's where i
harmonize
harmonize and then yield to it inside of
it
do not
block it that's not aikido
inside
strike
i'm gonna give you one a little one okay
because it looks like i'm pushing
[Music]
okay try it
there's a sequence of operations so as
as he goes you can go a little quicker
right
that that's the striking part that does
happen okay so you hit
i'll give you a little strength
okay that is happening got it
so but if you pay attention
after you hit
now you use those two hands in your
adhesion
to do the cookie nugget okay
so
you're not just going cookie nugget
you see that
but nor are you just going boom
so you're going to hit
there's a percussiveness there
that then goes
into
that adhesion do you see that
i'll try to accentuate it a little bit
more
[Music]
so i don't want to just be standing here
there's no cookie noggin now
oh
not out of here disconnected
okay
good
keep going
nope
that's a block you gotta have more
chemistry follow it going up throw the
same
there you go
right you're on the insteps fix your
feet fix your feet nope try it again be
ready don't be off you can listen to me
and be ready
good again
switch rolls
nope you're late you're late kimusu
catch it coming up be ready
you're striking the same way tristan
you're not doing a strike you're doing a
shoulder grab
you're doing the same strike you were
doing as
nagia go
bring your elbow in come on
bring your elbow in
switch your kiss alright on both sides
now
[Music]
you're a little late catch the key
misubi all right
little knight switch rolls
straighten your back don't punch